sporty approachable insecure welcome to
my youtube channel hi guys my name is
grace Helbig if you do not know now you
know your life is different now I don't
know about you but so far this video is
egg-cellent yes I do try really hard to
be quirky don't believe me I went to my
Twitter and asked you guys what kind of
video you wanted to see today and a lot
of you said some sort of Olympic themed
video and more specifically reviewing
all the outfits at the parade of Nations
during the Olympics Opening Ceremony in
Rio I have not watched any of the
Olympics at all whatsoever I did see
that the first u.s. a gold medal went to
a young girl in a in the rifle
competition so yeah we do not know the
parade of Nations is one each country
that is participating in the Olympics is
paraded through the Olympic arena and
welcomed by all the people that are
there and all the athletes from that
country wear something special I guess
it's like the Met Gala of professional
sports I don't know if there are
particular or specific guidelines to
what you're supposed to wear if there's
some sort of theme like the Met Gala and
I have not googled it because I just
didn't want to but looking through the
majority of these photos already I would
assume that the theme this year is prep
school let me show you why okay
Australia okay um this is like the
private school for Abercrombie & Fitch
models or these are just a bunch of
extras from that shows you may private
school girl this is very Hogwarts golf
tournament and there's some of the
Australian women just a bunch of very
fit Hermione's very athletic and then we
have the United States of America who
looked like the rival prep school of
Australia this opening ceremony needs
more Blazers and designed by Ralph
Lauren so what do you expect this looks
very very well
you look like all the kids that I just
hated and was afraid of in the
fictitious prep school I went to in my
mind very athletic synagogue these women
look incredible they look like some very
fashion-forward human Laffy Taffy's and
they are laughing and tapping all the
way through that arena they're having a
great time and they look right I love
you though Croatia they love a good
summer picnic blanket they look like a
very excited NASCAR pit crew and/or
they're all doing Avril Lavigne cosplay
Barry van very representative of Croatia
very athletic Canada wow this is Canada
it looks like Canada just some oversized
ill-fitting red blazers with Canada over
the back of it very DIY tails
sort of on the back this does look like
you gave athletes a sewing machine and
ask them to make their own outfits for
the opening ceremonies and it's cute Oh
Canada hungry these are the women from
hungry and they look like a bunch of
ladies out to brunch that are all
silently pissed that they were the same
thing especially not open they're going
up to you bottom of samosas and like
two-thirds of them are not wearing
panties I like that they all wore
matching wedges I feel like these could
all be my cousin's you know very
athletic aruba I love this if you're
going to play that blazer game you just
play it hard as look at these we got
some bright baby blue blazers what
some hats and some pink Blazers taking
up the rear and wow just go for it
because my uncle I got divorced and just
decided to change it up a little bit
alright here's some Miami advice keep
doing what you're doing
Slovakia Slovakia looks like they're
wearing some very cute Christmas themed
gap leggings very athletic bermuda
wearing Bermuda shorts because they're
not afraid to be obvious but I like to
imagine that instead of it being Bermuda
shorts that people are the inspiration
for this outfit it's like dad getting
dressed for work but the house caught on
fire and he had to run out of the house
half dressed very athletic
Oh Tonga this is the man who stole the
whole show of the opening ceremonies
Tonga if there is a baby oil shortage in
Rio I think we know where we can find
some genius making sure he's not going
to check tonight and that's important
also I like that that man behind him is
clearly looking at him just being like
scary said he was gonna wear the Blazer
like the rest of us and [ __ ] Gary [ __ ]
you Gary you said you'd wear the red
blazer no Indonesia yes this is what I'm
here for
this is what makes the Olympics so
bright look at that they're having a
great time they say your navy blue plane
Blazers USA
we're Indonesia and we're gonna make
sure you know it this is incredible that
we went holding that giant hat on her
head I feel like she's crushed so many
of our vertebraes I think her neck
probably used to be longer than it is
now but you know that pride Cook Islands
this looks great I genuinely like these
outfits I think you look like you're one
collective newlywed couple that's on
vacation and decided to get the matching
outfits at the store and the hotel that
you're staying at to be cute and here's
the Brazilian team they're running for
some reason I think out of excitement
hopefully not as they relate to their
own Olympics I like to a man
Genet they'd all decided just on wearing
the dresses and then they saw all the
other teams enter the stadium wearing
Blazers and they were like we need
Blazers guys let's get Blazers and they
all just ran and got Blazers and put
them over there their dress is cute very
athletic
South Africa yes this looks like a Missy
Elliott music video and I'm all for it
Norway they look like a bunch of fun
drunk uncles out on the town they
obviously look like actual drunk uncles
that don't know how they make down to
the arena without anyone stopping them
and so they're just kind of trying to
blend in and play cool but that guy
looks good in a half his moment fun
Porto Rico yeah this looks like a
bachelor party at a golf tournament I'm
into this get girl Sweden could this be
more Swedish looking you all do yellow
very well I love to that you're all
going for the clown your skirt short
looks but this very Swedish looking
girls I green your way I'm completing
Sweden I'm rolling my shorts very
athletic but I have to say I think my
favorite fashion look of the night were
the human directional arrows that we're
telling all of the athletes which way
they should walk look at that I love a
boxy shape top and they're just all
doing it so well it looks good on
everyone okay well there's my review of
the parade of Nations the opening
ceremonies of the Olympics for this year
in Rio let me know what you guys thought
let me know who your favorite country
look was also if you enjoyed this or you
hated this video please subscribe to
this youtube channel because you know
you could be one of those arrow people I
mean we all we should aspire to that we
should it's good I don't know
Malaysia taking this big orange is the
new black pants bye